deutschland ist die führende
automobilnationen und will das auch
bleiben ohne elektromobilität wird das
aber nicht funktionieren und die wird
ihrem durchbruch nur erreichen wenn die
infrastruktur gut genug ist um der
reichweiten angst der deutschen etwas
entgegenzusetzen
die bundesregierung steckt mit einer
million ladestellen bis 2030 ein hohes
ziel und die automobilkonzerne kommen
dabei ganz gut weg denn sie stehen unter
immensem druck klicks und science
fiction gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert ich locker nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen in deutschland kommen auf
eine ladestation neuen elektroautos
statistisch gesehen sind die fahrer und
fahrerinnen von e-autos damit gut
versorgt aber eben nur statistisch die
öffentlichen ladesäulen sind einfach
schlecht verteilt und in einigen städten
und besonders in ländlichen gebieten ist
die versorgung nicht ausreichend am
besten ist derzeit münchen mit 1.103
öffentlich zugänglichen ladepunkten
aufgestellt dicht gefolgt von hamburg
mit 1070 und berlin mit 974 stationen
mit größerem abstand folgen stuttgart
mit 4 5 dann düsseldorf mit 225 und
leipzig mit 215 ladepunkten und in köln
wo ich aber zu binden sind wirklich kaum
ladesäulen zu finden peinlich auch bei
den bundesländern führen die bayern mit
insgesamt 5700 ladestationen hessen zum
beispiel kommt dagegen nur auf 1700
stück aktuelle zahlen des
bundesverbandes der energie und
wasserwirtschaft zeigen dass sich für e
mobilisten schon einiges getan hat strom
fürs auto kann man in deutschland an
rund 24 000 öffentlich zugänglichen
ladepunkten zapfen das sind fast 8000
mehr als noch vor einem jahr was einen
ordentlichen zuwachs von 50 prozent
bedeutet 15 prozent davon sind schnell
ladesäulen trotzdem machen vielerorts
lange anfahrtswege und zugeparkte lade
sollen den alltag mit elektroautos
einfach zu unbequem um massentauglich zu
sein dagegen will die bundesregierung
etwas unternehmen und hat große ziele
für deutschland gesetz bis 2030 sollen
eine million ladepunkte für elektroautos
geschaffen werden für diese sorgen
hauptsächlich die energieunternehmen
drei viertel aller ladestationen werden
von ihnen aufgebaut und betrieben für
2020 planen sie
4000 weitere stationen damit ist die
energiewirtschaft die treibende kraft
der deutschen elektro mobilität aber
auch an anderen stellen soll angesetzt
werden tankstellen sollen in zukunft bis
auf absolute ausnahmefälle verpflichtet
werden ladesäulen anzubieten auch
supermärkte und geschäfte könnten
aufgefordert werden lade plätze
aufzubauen an denen die autofahrer und
fahren auch nachts auftanken können
neben den öffentlichen spielen aber auch
die privaten ladepunkte eine wichtige
rolle
die seit dem letzten autogipfel endlich
in den fokus gerückt sind die meisten
autos fahren ständig zwischen
arbeitsplatz und wohnsitz hin und her
wirklich alltagstauglich wird ein
elektroauto für viele fahrer und
fahrerinnen also erst wenn es dort auch
geladen werden kann die bundesregierung
plant deshalb den einbau von
ladestationen finanziell zu fördern
vermieter sollen diesen in der garage
ihrer mieter künftig nur noch in
ausnahmefällen verweigern dürfen
außerdem sollen hausbauer für solche
stationen vorsorgen müssen und das
stromtanken auf der arbeit soll
weiterhin steuerfrei bleiben wichtig ist
auch dass die kaufprämien für
elektrofahrzeuge verlängert und erhöht
werden denn die autos sind für viele
menschen immer noch unbezahlbar
erstaunlich ist allerdings dass auch
hochpreisige autos stärker gefördert
werden sollen und die preisobergrenze
dafür sogar von 60 auf 65.000 euro
erhöht werden soll
hier haben sich eindeutig die
automobilkonzerne durchgesetzt die
drängen mittlerweile selbst auf einen
schnellen ausbau der ladeinfrastruktur
der marktführer vw fordert als
verbindliches ziel bis 2021 die
öffentlichen ladepunkten auf 80 bis 100
tausend zu erweitern
eine weitere forderung aus der
automobilindustrie ist die verkürzung
der bearbeitungszeit für anträge zu
neuen ladestationen die momentan bei
durchschnittlich acht monaten liegt das
ist schon eine menge liegt unseren
automobilherstellern jetzt plötzlich das
klima so sehr am herzen vermutlich nicht
vielmehr sind es die eu-auflagen die sie
erfüllen müssen und sie jetzt zum
handeln zwingen um die klimaziele für
2030 zu erreichen müssen bis dahin zehn
millionen e autos auf den straßen sein
aktuell sind es erst etwa 220.000
zugelassene fahrzeuge und ohne ein
flächendeckendes ladennetz wird man
nicht ausreichend kunden und kundinnen
für die elektrisch betriebenen autos
begeistern können und es werden sich
immer längere schlangen
an den öffentlichen ladestationen bilden
das setzt die automobilbranche unter
druck dazu kommen milliarden die in neue
technologien investiert werden müssen um
die elektromobilität vorwärts zu bringen
und bei vielen firmen ist eine schlechte
ertragslage durch den abschwung der
automärkte der fall vor allem zulieferer
kämpfen deshalb mit kurzarbeit und
stellenabbau die ig metall fordert
unterstützung für kleinere und
mittelständische unternehmen die vom
wandel zur elektromobilität betroffen
sind und die von den banken kein geld
mehr bekommen es aber benötigen um in
ihren betrieben den umstieg von
verbrennungsmotoren hin zur
elektromobilität zu schaffen die großen
hersteller machen hingegen weiterhin
milliardengewinne vor diesem hintergrund
scheint es fast lächerlich dass die
industrie sich nur dazu verpflichten
15.000 lage stellen aufzubauen und das
vorwiegend an ihren eigenen standorten
während in den nächsten jahren 3,5
milliarden euro an steuergeldern in den
ausbau der infrastruktur investiert
werden sollen aber dann die ladesäulen
per preispolitik wie unity an bestimmte
hersteller bevorzugt ja zu vermieten und
dann wird auch noch gelogen dass sich
die balken biegen
die lade schock skandal zehnfacher preis
und interview fake anklicken anschauen
und unbedingt exotische abonnieren alles
über die umwelt und uhren es ist auch
noch gut fürs karma also bis dann bleibt
dran